when you when you put out
um when i see you um
did you have any hesitation about
putting that out or shooting the video
that way
no i don't know it's just [ __ ]
i ain't gonna count when i uploaded the
preview that she had a million views on
my [ __ ]
on my instagram so when i was going
through the comments they were like um
it was like a whole bunch of suggestions
they said dude
hannah montana party in the usa they
were saying all kind of crazy [ __ ]
on bro but what stuck out to me the most
was on the fantasia [ __ ] and a lot of
other artists was calling me telling me
to do that [ __ ] you know what i'm saying
so i went to the studio i had told the
internet to pull up the beat
that and i made like the um i punched in
on the chorus first i ain't even go
straight into the verse i went straight
to the chorus like
because i already had it in my mind what
i wanted to say so yeah when i did that
and i like finished the song i would
divide them tight i swear to god so
i say this [ __ ] and go bar on bro
i just left the studio after that got a
song about it do you find yourself um
like moving around like like i mean
obviously you're out here in la you know
what i'm saying
yeah but i can only assume like
you have to be somewhat paranoid to be
around certain parts like not not saying
like you're scared
but you always got to be on your toes
low-key with the kind of [ __ ] you
[ __ ] with you know what i'm saying
like yeah yeah
i'm like tight and then she's so crazy
bro
like let's go back to when you were in
other cities they showed you love but i
came out here
and there's no count so many games
reached out to me bro
like on some old i ain't gonna say the
gang name they bought me like you know
what i'm saying some polls and [ __ ] like
you good here bro like protect yourself
just bring that [ __ ] back when you leave
tight [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying people got
respect for me in the screech like you
know what i'm saying
and i fought with [ __ ] like and i'm
real dear tied in you know what i'm
saying so
it is the way i little like uh i know
the like consequences of how i'm living
so
i don't know you're at peace with that
yeah
because it's like this the way i'm
living like i gotta you gotta accept the
consequence like
even when i was born bro even though i
know what i was getting myself into
i had a chance to change my life plenty
of time when i was young but it was just
like this what it was like that's how i
want to live
i'm saying would could anything ever
happen to get you and ace to sit across
the table from each other and
have a discussion i don't know sure but
just just just you know something that's
not like
you know person to person put everything
on the table and try to move past it is
that something you think could ever even
happen
uh to be honest
i couldn't answer that question i really
don't know
honey i don't know i don't know
because he's younger than you right no
he's older than me oh he's older than
you oh [ __ ] i didn't because i remember
i saw something
on youtube you were saying that like
back in the day like like uh when you
was rapping
yeah cass was in your videos yeah they
used to be well not ace crew but the
other people on the song though
my videos yeah they used to be in my
videos shaking eyes
yeah man i just you know i can't have
you come on here and not try to you know
be like hey look bro like
i don't want to see anybody pass away
bro i'm already knowing though like you
know what i'm saying
i'm knowing what it is every time i open
my [ __ ] phone every week i feel
like it's some other rapper
you know uh dying bro and you know i
think that um
i'm not gonna lie man coming from like
an older generation
the [ __ ] is low keys like i like
disturbing to me when i see this [ __ ]
and the other thing that i really gotta
like you know
the whoever is whether it's whoever ace
assigned to
or whoever you're working with like i
feel like
there's more that obviously this record
is huge for you right is this
was this was this record probably the
most viral moment you've had
i've been at like 7 million in a week
and it's almost like
yo the more negativity and [ __ ] that
transpires the more money gets
brought in and that's a crazy two to me
it's like
okay boom before they sound right here
right
i draw a beat box with my cousin coach
right
like i said i had like 460 followers i'm
at like 641
43 canines some [ __ ] off of just like
nothing show prices i'm booked up nah
i'm like
money going off listen beef is always
good for business but it's not it's not
good
for your life for your life yeah because
what if you know you mentioned that
you're you know your car got shot and
your ex got hit what if you know i don't
know if you have any children or not
no but you know that's good but like
imagine maybe you know somebody else
that's close to you was in that car or
maybe you know she would have got hit
and passed away i just
you know what i'm saying i'm just trying
to bring some reason to the table
because i just feel like you know
everyone's from the same city everyone's
getting money
it seems like jacksonville i've never
seen
uh so much division in a in a region
that's like
it's crazy even like because this bottom
got him kids from there right
yeah he from like one no one in the hood
did he from right here from dirt world
that's like a hood that we fought with
in jacksonville yeah even like you know
people got problems with him you know i
mean those you know the snitching
allegations all that [ __ ] like
i just feel like [ __ ] for a city that's
fresh to
you know being like the it city in
hip-hop
no one's really moving together i know
you got short but it just feels like
man that [ __ ] is crazy bro like what are
you telling it is though
i was thinking one day though like when
i was in the car i'm like damn
imagine if all of us were just together
on small city [ __ ]
and if y'all all were together imagine
how crazy it would be it should be crazy
like if you think to like back in the
day like when the way miami was moving
together when it was ross and trina and
trick like everybody was a movement it
was
powerful you couldn't stop it you know
even in new york and in la
like right now in l.a all the young kids
in l.a are all moving together like in
the same direction you know what i'm
saying older generations you probably
couldn't say that for but
i just you know yeah if y'all all
somehow figured a way to just
and and again i'm not here to tell you
that that's possible because you
there has been people's lives lost yeah
so when that happens
i can't tell you how to react or how to
deal with that pain period you know what
i'm saying or maybe
but i just know that like more
you know more bloodshed is not gonna
you're not gonna get not gonna be at
peace with that man
you know what i'm saying it might feel
it might feel that way but
it's it's just you know 20 30 years from
now you know
if you make it god bless you know what
i'm saying